في خبر مفجع بصراحه جرينا اليوم وعليه
علامات استفهام كثير الخبر بيتكلم عن
تسجيل اصغر اصابه في العالم بالزهايمر
لمراهق صيني عمره 19 سنه والخبر نازل في
مجله طبيه كمان الاغرب اكثر واكثر انه
المريض ما عنده اي تاريخ من المرض في
العيله ولا عنده اي طفره جينيه بتسبب
المرض قبل تسجلت حالات زهايمر لمرضى اول
العشرين والثلاثين لكن جميعهم كان عندهم
الطفره او الاستعداد الجيني بحسب الدراسه
اللي صار مع الشاب انه بدا من عمر 17 سنه
يشكي من ضعف في شويه في الذاكره ومشاكل في
التركيز وردات فعل متاخره وصعوبه في
القراءه ولا مره عند الدكتور كانت حالته
صعبه لدرجه انه مو فاكر ايش اكل قبل بيوم
وكانت خلاص انه يترك المدرسه اللي كان في
اخر سنه فيها الزهايمر يعني مثل العلم
المعروف انه يصاب فيه الناس من 65 سنه
وطالع وبين خمسه لعشره في المئه فقط من
المصابين في ناس بيكونوا اصغر من كده
الدراسه في المجله العلميه قالت انه قد
يصبح حل الاشخاص او الشباب المصابين بمرض
الزهايمر احد اكثر الاسئله العلميه تحديا
في المستقبل لكن بغض النظر عن التحدي
العلمي الناس مفجوعه من الخبر وبتقول كمان
يعني انه مرض جديد بدا يصيب الشباب وهل
المفروض يسوي شيء نحاول نحمي نفسنا
المفروض كمان نخاف يعني
المخ والاعصاب عشان يساعدنا انه نفهم من
هذا الموضوع اهلا فيك معنا تحت الهواء لما
تكلمنا
انه قد ما يكون زهايمر ايش ممكن يكون اذا
ما كان زهايمر يا مرحبا طبعا يعني هناك
اسباب كثيره جدا لحدوث مشاكل في الذاكره
والتركيز
وفي نفس المنطقه التي تحدث فيها يعني
الزهايمر
الاسباب كثيره ومتعدده خاصه عندما تحدث
لدى صغار السن في هذا العمر في الغالب
تكون مرتبطه اما بعد م تمرين الذاكره او
شيء متعلق بطفرات وراثيه مختلفه او متعلق
بالحاله النفسيه والصحه النفسيه
مثلا
الاكتئاب الشديد عدم تمرين الذاكره نقص
الفيتامين عدم تمرين الذاكره هذا الشيء
مقلق يا بروفيسور ايش يعني عدم تمرين
الذاكره عدم تمرير الذاكره الان نحن نعتمد
في كل شيء على الذاكره الالكترونيه
ارقام لا يحفظ حتى
المنازل يعني في السابق كان يعني نذهب لاي
مكان بالذاكره كما يحدث يعني في البلاك في
لندن الان على يعني اي مكان يعني حتى
الانسان لا يركز يعتمد فقط على الماب وعلى
يعني كل شيء على ذاكره فالذاكره تضمره كما
تضمر العضلات يعني اذا لم يتم التمرين
بنقرا وبنسمع حكاوي بعض وحتى برضه على
التلفون جالسين بتسوي اشياء برضه يعني
بتعلق بذاكرتنا هذا ما يعتبر تمرين
لا لا لا لا يعتبر تمرين هي
لا تعلى الذاكره مرور الكرام وتعلق
بهذاكر الموبوءه بالنسيان في هذا الزمن
تمرين الذاكره حفظ يعني اشياء
قصائد طويله
حفظ في السابق كان يحفظون القران الكريم
يحفظون معلقات يحفظون يعني يعني كل شيء
مرتبط بالذاكره حتى الذين يقودون في
الصحراء ويحفظون الطرق والنجم فالذاكره
دائما تكون متوهجه اما مشاكل الذاكره في
الوقت الحالي ليست كلها
ما بتعتبر تمرين
لا تعتبر تمرين لذاكره هي هي
لكنها تمرين
للقدرات الذهنيه المختلفه صادقه معك راح
احفظ معلقات ولا حسوي يعني الامور ولا
حشوف حاحفظ طرق ولا كذا حلعب على الجوال
افضل يعني او سلوكه انا بيتي معرفه ادله
يعني طيب وهذه حقيقه وليست مبالغه على
الهواء بس خليني ارجع للموضوع عشان الخبر
اللي شفناه صادم اذا كان زهايمر هل
الزهايمر ممكن يصيب الصغار بهذا السن
وخصوصا انه بيقولوا لا عنده تاريخ في
العيله يعني ولا جينات
هو هو يعني ليس من المؤكد
بالفعل انه هو الزهايمر لان الزهايمر
التشخيصه بنعم من البروتينات
وهذه لم توجد في هذا الشعب وجدت فقط في
السائل الشوكي يعني توجد في المخ وحتى وان
كان الزهايمر فهو حاله نادره جدا يعني لا
تعتبر شيء يثير القلق والخوف فقد تكون
حدثت نتيجه اما انها طفره جديده لم ترسم
بالطفرات السابقه المتعلقه
بجينات الزهايمر لم توجد فيه قد تكون طفره
قد يكون التهاب فيروسي نوع من الفيروسات
التي تؤدي الى تغيرات في في يعني معروف ان
ماده الماده البروتينيه المعروفه بالبريون
التي
تسب جنون البقر لدى الانسان جاكوب
اللي هو جنون البقر انتقل عن طريق
ما يعرف بشيء
يسمى
ولا تعرف حقيقته بالكامل الى الان ايضا
فيروس الذي يسبب نقص المناعه المكتسب قبل
ان الايدز ايضا يسبب ديمنشيا وضمور
في الذاكره بس
سريعاهم بيقولوا انه التحدي المستقبلي
حيكون في يعني معرفه اسباب اصابه الصغار
بالسن بالزهايمر والان صرنا بنشوف امراض
كنا معتدين انه عاده يصابوا فيها الكبار
في السن بنشوف الان صغار بيتم تشخيصهم
فيها ايش اللي متغير اذا في شيء متغير
المتغير نمط الحياه كله متغير
والتلوث الذي يحدث التلوث البيئي والتلوث
الالكتروني وطبيعه الغذاء وطبيعه ممارسه
يعني
الحياه من النوم المبكر من حالات القلق من
حالات الاكتئاب حالات التوتر
هناك اشياء كثيره جدا تغيرت حتى الساعه
البيولوجيه تغيرت يعني الناس لا ينامون
النوم الكافي في الوقت المناسب يعني
لان الكثير من الهرمونات والمواد الغذائيه
وعمليات الاكسده تتم في اوقات معينه يعني
الليل يعني
مثلا
شخصت حاله كل الناس اللي اعرفهم ما ابغى
فاول على نفسي سلامه قلبي يعني من اي شيء
بس انه كلنا كل الناس كذا يعني استغفر
الله العظيم عشان كده كلهم يشكون يعني
الان مثلا انا في عيادتي للمخ والاعصاب
قبل عشره سنوات كان معظم المرضى كبار
الصين الان
صغار السن الذين يشكونن بالقلق من الصداع
من التوتر من النسيان يعني كل هذه من
الارتجاف في اليد هزات عدم توازن تنمل في
الجسم الاشياء كلها يعني صارت لدى صغار
السن طيب
الحمد لله يا دكتور يعني معز انتهى وقتنا
لليوم لانه كنت يعني حتجيب لي انهيار عصبي
انا كمان يعني فكان معنا عز بخيت استشاري
المخ والاعصاب شكرا لك شكرا